what are the social benefits of being
vaccinated twice
i think they give you huge protection
gives people confidence
and also i think it protects other
people um
from from being uh infected so there are
huge benefits from
two two vaccinations absolutely yeah but
what about the social benefits i'm
thinking particularly about
looking at the figures 0.4 percent of
travelers that have
come back from ambassador countries have
tested positive that's 89 people out of
more than
almost 23 and a half thousand people
who've had two vaccines
should they have to uh quarantine on
their return from holiday so the
the figures that you uh quote i think
were stated in the times today
um and those figures don't tell the full
picture yes they are statistics
they're very encouraging but you can
appreciate that we want to keep people
as safe as possible and that's why we've
maintained the amber list
but do you acknowledge that people who
are having two jobs
are getting more and more frustrated
thinking okay i'm protecting other
people
but there have to be some other social
benefits for me whether that means i
don't have to quarantine
if i go on holiday or if i come into
contact with somebody who's had covered
i don't have to self-isolate which is in
fact what matt hancock is suggesting
so i totally get the frustration i mean
for for me uh it's been very difficult
because i want to
i want to go on holiday but i've chosen
uh not to because
of the restrictions the guidelines i
think it's a difficult one to balance
uh it's encouraging as you say the data
we've seen
from ambulance countries but at the
moment we want to take
an approach that's more safer rather
than sorry
and what about as i said developing from
matt hancock's uh wanting to ditch the
stay at home order
for people who have come in contact with
people who have covered if they've had
two
jabs yeah i think matt is clearly very
close to the information he's worked
extremely hard over more than a year now
and what he says
there's a lot of a force to what he says
i don't know what the final decision
will be
but as we've all always done through
this process uh we've been more cautious
perhaps than a lot of people would have
liked but of course we got a duty to
keep people safe
more cautious than perhaps you would
have liked but um
i'm sure you saw the scenes in leicester
square with the football
the scotland uh fans at the weekend
um no social distancing there at all
what's the government's view on that
i think it's really uh difficult because
we want people to act responsibly
and i saw the pictures as well i think
it's really concerning that
lots of people were congregating this
way but it's very difficult
uh thing to police um i mean i saw the
game as i think
uh you did it was rubbish it was a
rubbish game but that's
not if you're a scotland fan obviously
good morning everyone in scotland if
you're in england
maybe not so much putting the quality of
the football uh to one side
i think yeah it is a problem but again
we've got to do
to strike that balance between
essentially compelling people how to
behave and then giving guidelines so
that people can
accessibly in this instance it was very
concerning the behavior but you can
appreciate the
frustration then of the night time
industry and nightclub owners people who
we've got someone on
later on who has six theaters in the
west end and they're not allowed
to play at full capacity i get their
frustrations i mean as you said
we're going to do is we set out a road
map and hopefully on the 19th of july
uh everything can revert back to some
type of normality
could it be before the 19th of july i
think between you and me i would always
uh er on the side of caution and i would
look to the 19th of july it could be
before but i think that's unlikely do
you
well i don't know i mean that's just my
guess uh generally we've stuck to the
dates that we've said
um i remember in the previous dates
there was a lot of push to try and get
the dates the 12th of april earlier the
17th of may
earlier that didn't happen and i think
now i'm very focused on the 90th of july
the reason i'm slightly pressing you on
that is because there has been criticism
of the prime minister this morning
that he doesn't throw his net wide
enough to ask his ministers
and cabinet ministers permission he just
relies on a core group
of ministers and and from what you're
saying it does sound as though he
doesn't
he doesn't reach out to people like you
and say he doesn't so what's he saying
about the nineteen so
so you'll appreciate that uh today's the
21st so the 19th is four weeks time
and all through this process we've said
that we would take the decision a week
before
uh the actual date because the data's
moving around all the time but you
appreciate how frustrating that is for
the
night time industry that we've just
talked about trying to organize
reopening
i i fully appreciate that but kay you'll
know that
the coronavirus is quite unpredictable
we don't know where it'll be
even in two weeks time let alone four
weeks time and what the prime minister's
always said is that we've got to look at
the data in real time we've got to look
at the data
as it comes and then make a judgment
soon
in between the the dates that means that
we've got to
look at the data and we can't make a
decision a month
or five weeks before the actual date um
it's what we do knows it's costing us a
fortune and this pandemic how are we
going to pay for it
i think it's a very difficult question
to answer i'm hopeful
as business sector as you can imagine
that we can grow the economy
and that's in the past has always been
the best way
to raise tax revenue to grow an economy
have a prosperous economy
and then the tax revenue from a thriving
economy can pay down
some of the debt that's what's happened
in the past happened after the second
year this is a massive jet isn't it
the second one was a huge sure the
suggestion is that it's going to be a
pension rate
um that's flying a kite in the papers
this morning the telegraph particularly
i i don't think i mean obviously we're
discussing uh lots of things being
discussed in government i don't think
that that's
uh necessarily the way so you think a
triple lot will stay in place as far as
i'm pretty sure
the triple obviously the decision for
the chancellor but i'm pretty sure the
triple lock will stay
talk to me about by-elections uh you've
got an absolute kicking
uh last week um we for all sorts of
reasons sure
um batley and spen is looming on the
horizon uh we heard the former speaker
speaking yesterday john burke are here
on sky actually
suggesting that the prime minister only
has a nodding acquaintance with the
truth
um labour are pressing hard for a
planning debate planning was a big issue
as far as batman's
as far as amisham was concerned how
anxious are you about the first of july
because if you lose another one
it's a it's a lot of trouble look my
election is always difficult i mean you
and i remember uh by-elections were
always challenging have always been
challenging for governments
in fact it's very unusual for a city
government to win
a seat off the opposition as happened in
hartlepool uh six weeks ago so
by-elections are difficult i think it
was a very disappointing result uh
last week in cheshire and amisham and
we're looking to learn lessons from that
anyone would
try and learn lessons from what was a
very difficult uh set of results
but you're not a government that's used
to losing you seem to have been doing
very well
of late in previous elections is it down
to
uh planning and and the issues that we
saw there in amisham or is it a bigger
problem for you are you concentrating
too much on the red wall and ignoring
the blue wall i don't think that's true
i mean i think
as you know by-elections are always a
mixture of national issues and local
issues
i think last week in cheshire amisham
the the local issues
played quite strongly uh there was a lot
of talk about hs2 there was a lot of
talk about the government
people said people saying the government
wasn't listening on planning
we are listening we want to engage with
our mps i have a southern seat as well
where this is a big
a big issue and we want to engage now
about winning elections yes it's nice to
win elections but generally
as you remember uh governments tend to
lose by elections in
in midterm i mean that's what has
happened historically i think we've had
a good run
but uh we're not taking anything for
granted i think the the election
next week will be very difficult for us
uh it's a historic labor seat
um but we will try our best to win it
sounds good from what you're saying it
sounds as though you're setting yourself
up for failure
no not at all i mean i'm very realistic
and i look back
at lots of mid-term results which have
been very disappointing in government
for years
and i think it would be foolish for us
to expect a miraculous a really a really
good win i think we've got to just try
and
work hard for every vote be humble in
the face of
the voters and and see if we can get a
result
i'm not underestimating how difficult uh
batley and spen will be
where are we on the prime minister's
credibility though we talked about
uh the former speaker there saying that
you know he he
he he sees the truth uh maybe once every
leap year
and then we've seen dominic cummings
absolutely ripping him to bits he's
going to do it again later on today he's
going to have a live q a session
how much damage are noises off doing the
prime minister
i think the prime minister and what is
his great strength
is that he's very very focused on the
job at hand he's very very focused
on providing leadership and as you say a
lot of people
recognize that that's why we've had
successful results
in places like hartlepool which was
historically unprecedented
and he's very focused people say all
sorts of things about prime ministers
um from time to time uh sometimes they
say
bad things but that won't detract from
the prime minister's focus
on what is a very difficult situation
but when they impact on his credibility
that's when it starts to damage the
party that's when it starts to damage
the government
well i don't think they have necessarily
impacted on his credibility i mean i've
been reading about boris johnson for 30
years people have said all sorts of
things about him
uh in the past and nothing prime
minister nothing has uh really detracted
from
uh his focus on the job you'll remember
he's i mean he's done the job for nearly
two years now
and that whole period before the general
election in december 2019
there are all sorts of things being
written about the prime minister being
written about the party
being written about the fact that you
know we took the whip off of
people and all that sort of thing but we
were very focused the prime minister was
extremely focused
uh on getting a mandate on the election
uh and he remains very focused on
levelling up and
and driving his agenda so people like
dominic cummings and people like uh
uh the uh what's what's backhoe's first
name i've controlled
john virgo there you go are to be
ignored well i think
uh they can say what they say in the
media but our job as ministers
and the prime minister's job is to focus
on getting us out of a very difficult
situation with covid that's
100 of our our focus at the moment and
we cannot adjust what people like that
thing
well i read in the papers and and i
might make for my own judgments but i'm
100 focused on the job okay we also read
in the papers about a royal yacht
really um he wants to spend 200 million
pounds on it
um the prime minister apparently the
royal family don't want it
and the treasury the mod and the cabinet
office are all refusing
to pay for everybody's falling out
nobody wants this royal yet why does he
want one
i think there's a discussion in
government about uh the the yacht
i'm not sure any conclusions have been
reached and there's a degree of
agreement i mean i'm speaking to
colleagues and we're we're trying to
mull over the
those issues but i think it's a good
idea actually why do you think it's a
good idea because actually what it does
is that it represents
uh britain it's a symbol of britain and
if we're going on trade missions
that's exactly the way that we would uh
we would drive
uh trade and it's a symbol of britain
i'm sure it'll get much more
bang we'll get much more bang for our
buck from something like that uh than
than the opposite but if the royals
don't want to say who's going to get it
is it just going to be you and boris
it's not going to be just so i'm just
going to be him i'm not that big i can't
up probably seriously but at the
moment
you know we do have uh trade delegations
we have people representing
the country to try and get really good
deals uh liz trust my colleague is doing
a fabulous job in that regard
and that sort of thing is is something
that can drive
uh trade as a symbol but you can see how
it might be ridiculed by
voters in battley and spain uh when
they're they're struggling to feed their
kids at the moment and we're talking
about spending 200 million quid on our
yacht that the royals don't want
it's a huge amount of money but then it
would only be
the decision to spend that money would
only be made if we felt that we could
get a return
from something as symbolic as that and
and it would be something which would
really enhance what we call our soft
power you know in terms of doing deals
it's not a decision that's going to be
made anytime soon well it's it's
something that's being discussed i can't
tell you when exactly the decision was
made
okay it's good to talk to you thank you
so much for taking the time to join us
thank you really appreciate it